[Musique]
la combi c'est la voilà bon soir
matthieu delormeau comment ça va en
revanche les arts revient à tuer et s'il
a arrété de mossoul et agata on lancera
la pub tout à l'heure tu nous remercie
alors mathieu mois et rit oui alors
qu'est ce que tu as un cadeau pour moi
alors absolument rien j'ai pensé à vous
ce week-end oui c'est moi ou alors
chacun d'eux pour voyager de manière
faire un cadeau pour être plus tard soit
acheter quelque chose je vous comprends
ya deux manières de faire un cadeau soit
il peut acheter quelque chose tout le
monde peut le faire voilà c'est vulgaire
nana j'ai pas voulu faire ça
soit on peut se déplacer donné de sa
personne ah non mais je préférais de
bons série moi qui l'ait fait nous tes
amis stars et bien donc je suis allé
voir les autres de tes amis stars way
qui t'ont laissé un message
j'étais avec ma petite caméra regarde
que j'ai chopé pour toi tu es mais tu
lisais pas regarde pas qui m'a regarde
les anniversaires
très sincèrement et rend mon argent je
t'aime verts c'est un joyeux
anniversaire à pitre syrie bon
anniversaire swing je ne t'ai jamais
trouvé aussi belle que ce matin là mon
cyril je te souhaite un joyeux
anniversaire croire en revers lifté
comme ça pour notre marche c'est une
bonne chose que de dar k et je t'aime
très fort mois d'anniversaire
je voudrais remercier pour tout ce que
tu as fait pour moi et tous souhaité un
très bon anniversaire
et cyril a pu voter je souhaite un bon
anniversaire mon chéri série c'est ton
anniversaire
quand nra zo commentaires j'imagine que
tu sors et délavé le matin pour te dire
combien je t'aime et je t'aime bien
bravo pour ce qu'on peut faire
bassiri je souhaite un joyeux
anniversaire nous dit pas ou plus vieux
que moi maintenant tu embrasses pouvoir
je les adversaires 18 ans génial j'aime
cette personne même si c'est le plus
grand discours est rentabilisé il a
produit un documentaire la semaine
dernière alors qu'il devait s'appeler
bonne anniversaire baba et il a fait
déjà les trucs en stock et ça n'a rien à
vous salissez tout quoi la paire
d'années voilà c'est toujours une banane
si jamais j'ai mis un petit coup de mou
va très bien alors faites vous plaisir
et coûté à vous faire c'est nous qui
payons sa selle après ça vous qui tenez
à votre âge
j'espère pas avoir un petit creux mois
[Musique]
alors valérie benaïm gourgeon ouais
ouais alors moi aussi j'ai un
anniversaire un cadeau d'anniversaire
pour vous mr ce n'est pas matériel parce
que vous n'êtes pas un garçon ville
et voilà et j'ai le cadeau que moi j'ai
plutôt un garçon quand paul nom et le
calme je vais vous faire assure pense va
vous faire extrêmement plaisir parce que
c'est une cause à laquelle vous êtes
très attaché
ayez un garçon qu'on a reçu 6 sur ce
plateau qui s'appelle gamal ah oui les
gammes à lille il était avec les anges
de la rue qu'il est qui l'ont aidé il
cherchait à avoir une famille d'accueil
et suite à son passage dans l'émission
et a une famille à paris qui va la voir
qui va l'accueillir chez lui chez elle
par don et donc il va pouvoir rester à
paris pour continuer ses soins dans le b
dans les hôpitaux de la rue surtout
bravo bravo robert les ventes de la
riversimple bon plaisir vous est-ce
qu'il est là non il est pas la gamme à
la corde moi je fais de gros bisous et
donc tout va bien pour les bassins
trailer cadeaux merci valérie bdc fait
maxime gagné âge un beau cadeau un
cadeau virtuel
si je vous dit rov si je vous dis boba
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je vis de la foi la foi vous connaissez
un estomac
si je vous dis ppn îlots vous n'êtes pas
encore presse que la nouvelle relève du
rap français est là et vous souhaite un
très joyeux anniversaire
regardez bah oui vous allez reconnaître
bas c'est bon bah ouais c'est makgoba
combat on va regarder makgoba fils
thibault hba1c pour toi mon baba mon
poto du pied car boulogne billancourt 92
semble j'irai jusqu'au bout pour droite
je suis pas un fond bout cheney et les
ouates envoie le son d'un cours joyeux
bab anniversaire joyeux bab anniversaire
tu peux pas décrire toute la lumière
doit lui verser 30 ou l'anniversaire à
semer carnières
[Applaudissements]
qu'il faille universel géré des joyeux
baba anniversaire ça va ça va resté sain
bon soir merci d'être là alors j'ai un
message vraiment particulier de
quelqu'un que vous adorez ah oui c'est
le président d'un club de foot dont vous
êtes fan c'est le président de guingamp
nordstrand des plats qui a tenu à vous
laisser un message dans regarde et je
sais goaleador sur six livres c'est
bertrand desplat la bonne anniversaire
alors tout le monde le sait pour votre
anniversaire vous voulez vous faire un
cadeau formidable
vous avez envie de racheter le club d'en
avant guingamp c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est vous on vous l'avait rendue
publique par contre j'ai juste un petit
message de nous tous pas de problème
mais rajouter quelques zéros et à la fin
évidemment bon anniversaire série
géniale
est ce qu'il a fait pour bien d'autres
exceptionnels où l'on m'a saoulé
guingamp fait qu'ils vont garder
franchement c'est un super président
club remercie gilles ça me fait plaisir
un schéma des beaux cadeaux alors vous
savez on est dans le havre
[Rires]
regardez le bien parce qu'ils sont en
train de vous en personnaliser un
scepticisme est pompier volontaire des
biens
bon les endroits à risque il ajouté
samedi soir concret une chorale un très
beau de un groupe de rock formidable
pour les pupilles des pompiers
volontaires je les adore bon les zombies
en rien à un très très beau qu'à 25 ans
qui s'appelle nicolas qui aimerait
beaucoup entrer en contact avec kelly et
qu'il avait toutes ses chances à côté de
maxime et jean-michel
[Applaudissements]
alors oui on va se faire en deux cas on
ya celui ci entre le pas sur le web
après deux mois mais couvrir un homme
qui a tout on a tricoté un truc non la
rivière mais quand je ne sais pas c'est
quoi ces décodeurs vocoder way bbc quoi
mais après afin de cerner le vrai le
mien ça c'est le cadeau qu'on m'avait
offert sa non ça c'est le cadeau
préventive pour vous comprenez ma fin de
semaine y aura le mien elle a fait un
vide greniers quoi j'adore isabelle mais
c'est vraiment un cadeau pourri d'arabes
ça peut vous faire arrêter de décoder à
quoi arrêter le tgv
[Applaudissements]
c'est le terme des 2 ânes alors achi le
rachat de voir alors tout d'abord un
moulin à musique la caisse k1 mouly
heynckes ça veut dire bon anniversaire
en berbère exactement anberber voilà je
prendrais bien sûr tous les berbères lui
percer le personnaliser un peu tout de
même
et pire vous saouler que pendant des
années j'ai interviewé des gens dans la
rue pour le règne de leur avis alors il
ya un jeune garçon qui s'appelle hakim
qui fait ça bien dans l'émission à
chaque semaine et chaque show même île à
l intérieur des gens sur certains noms
de personnalités aujourd'hui il à risque
ont interviewé excuse moi j'aimerais le
croire il ya eu d'accord c'est mieux que
moi encore cyril hanouna d'accord j'aime
beaucoup les émetteurs même quoique in
bon c'est si regarde regarde à
gravelines domicile regarde ramener au
moins une petite ne pas une petite peau
comme si tout devait sourire à celle de
la france à kim jae-ho xi linosa et pour
ton anniversaire très haut je suis allé
voir dans la rue ce que les gens vont me
dire excellent nom x6 la mena vous
n'aimez pas vous aimez quillier ruquier
non plus voilà il aime pas du tout
reconnu
vous êtes version de enrico macias ont
diminué
[Musique]
pas reconnu oui c'est la nonna delpech a
vu six venus à 30 ans ouais parce que
j'avais qui fait ce qui est grave si tu
devais lui offrir un cadeau pour son
anniversaire ce serait quoi encore ce
temps durant ces temps durs
il serait bien aussi qui changea belou
qu'il enlève cette march datant ça fait
50 ans qu'on le voit et que cette barre
si vous devez lutter un cadeau serait
quand même un string
on veut te rends string ce soir sa
convenance excellent [ __ ] la balle un
bon cyril tout à ce rite otages restent
déversèrent ça ça fait plutôt plaisir
moi je voulais vraiment acheté un petit
cadeau mais vu ce que tu me payes très
haut je pense que c'est à toi de moi
j'étais un petit cadeau elle est super
excellent zago élevé jusqu'à sa barre
jusqu'à quand cette bande jusqu'à quand
je rigolais alors les chéris merci merci
à que c'est ça allô c'est le csa
allô allô au michel drucker mais chez
les
joe phrase là ou plus bas à l'eau michel
oui je te souhaite un heureux
anniversaire 34 ans est magnifique
merci mon michel est un amour mon chéri
comment ça va bien
comme tous ceux qui t'appelle je te
kiffe grave comme on dit chez les jeunes
ce qu'il faut musciales et je te
souhaite plein de choses mais surtout
cyril oui on est tous les fruits tous
les deux fils de médecin paris il
nettoie une histoire arrivée reçoit là
la route est encore longue
la graphie pas trop je sais pas mais
c'est pas moi qui me fatigue c'est eux
qui me fatigue non nommé ne me fais pas
unis une médiamétrie est due à 9h04
n'atteint plus grand porte inquiète par
bruxelles
à la lecture des oignons et coup sûr ce
serait une bonne chose mais c'est un
très fort aux biches est le meilleur le
meilleur est à venir d'un hameau michel
s'embrasser thouars michel drucker est
ce que je lui fais l'adorent
pour cette édition dans l'immédiat mais
ce soir c'est un grand évènement est
l'anniversaire de cyril hanouna en
première partie jean michel a fait un
magnifique cadeau puisque camilo est
venue chanter pour cyril elle était
vêtue d'une magnifique combinaison et à
lui offert la même et comme cyril à un
corps de mannequin sous lui va et il a
décidé de passer la combinaison pour
dans la publicité
alors comme la télévision c'est aussi le
plaisir des yeux albert ii messieurs
pour vous ce soir cyril hanouna
[Applaudissements]
ballet chérie je vous le vouliez ou non
et ouais c'est pas sûr il vient ça vient
améliorer les bars vivre ouais ouais ça
c'est quand même bien amélioré les
bagues niveau des packs et ou non mais
vous êtes beaucoup mais vous va bien moi
je voudrais la vie de rocaille un mois
c'est marqué x-ore mixant le chien ça
rappelle un kiki cosmodôme vient en tout
cas vous êtes droitier
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
diversité ils avaient le dos 40 on est
en direct et franchement je suis très
très heureux d'être avec vous
aujourd'hui qu'il ya un petit cadeau
avant qu'on fasse les coups de coeur
rocailleux ben moi je les vois je veux
faire j'ai envie de prendre une place
pour la tournée de maxime ce que j'ai
découvert son super flou tout à leurs
ébats très bien bah vous démarrez bien
donner des bons cadeaux leader merci à
monsieur patate l'année prochaine on va
louer les anniversaires c'est tous les
ans alors je sais que vous avez une
passion pour les spectacles vivants
rémy aller dans les salles voir des gens
se produire sur scène je n'ai vécu assez
durement à huy forcé ou de 52 ans mais
vous êtes venus donc ce soir comme vous
avez beaucoup de monde
mon spectacle je vous offre 1 alors je
m'en tire pas ce que je vais vous dire
la vérité
l'enveloppé a été faite par la
production à et la production il voilà
comment il pense que vous appelez cyril
anouma et donc quand vous aimez les
strips vivant je vous ai offert une
place pour julia cour des grands
[Applaudissements]
les olympiens places offertes catégories
u10 normal voilà non numérotés ben hamou
julien je vais aller de voir la comédie
de boulevard et cartonne déjà bon juge
je sais que j'ai remis à mathieu ils
sont allés ce week-end et ils ont adoré
il va merci mon jean luc très beau
cadeau avant de passer aux coutures et
aux coups de gueule en fait tout à
l'heure je vous ai parlé de zamal oui
bah il est là et il est là pour nous et
au gabon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les sueurs vous avez vous avez recueilli
bien mal alors lui et ses seins à moi ça
l'est depuis bayer il a dormi à la
maison c'est vrai vous avez vu ça dans
la vie c'est ça j'ai vu jamal j'ai vu
j'ai dit je pense à coup téléphone
valérie m'a dit de venir aussi robert
mathis bâti c'est toi mon chéri anthony
ça vous êtes content d'avoir l'air mal à
la maison oui et les gentils
elle va vous aider pour les devoirs est
tous d'accord 1 et et jamal d'un amour
féroé je suis content pour toi tu peux
pas savoir si tu ne mérites pas d'amour
et bravo aux anges de la route vers son
équipe face à des cadeaux merci mais non
merci le shérif merci beaucoup
bravo bravo va les rivières si valérie
elle est franchement et merci à vous et
c'est grâce à tpm paix grâce surtout aux
anges de la rue qui font un travail
formidable bras beaumont robert était
une bombe mon chéri matt kelly d'amour
savoie cadeau pour moi c'est pour vous
les montrer en images la personne qui
m'a inspiré être dj c'est un grand
honneur pour moi c'est vrai
[Musique]
pourquoi nous les cercueils ont l'air
on a tous à paris olympio pipe on l'a vu
dans mes amis du bon score
on l'a vu dans sa radio à cela pour ses
adieux
cyril a conduit à travers tout ce soit
merci qui merci sait même pas d'où ça
vient alléger